this is the biggest way that this has
impacted me is we were in New York City
on Wednesday taping the Mel Robbins show
we had already cancelled all live
audiences out of an abundance of caution
we were due to tape all the way through
the end of next week and I after
Wednesday show walked into the control
room with the entire team and expected
to just debrief on the show and Mindy
Borman my executive producer turned to
me and said that's it were a wrap were
dumb and then they announced the two
employees at CBS where we tape had
tested positive and that the building
that we were in was getting quarantined
and just like that my dream of hosting a
daytime talk show over no time to say
goodbye no time to get complete no time
to thank the cast no time to get my
stuff out of the office it was run
upstairs grab what you can from the
greenroom and get the out of the
building and it was so discombobulating
that I think it took me about 36 hours
to get my feet back on the planet
there's a really powerful concept that I
learned from Carrie Lorenz called span
of control and it's being borrowed as a
military term and I'm gonna tell you how
I've used it okay in order to quiet the
anxiety because I don't know about you
but when I start to get anxious about
all the uncertainty I feel my heart race
I feel my mind start to spin I start to
think about what if this what if that
what if the other thing what if another
thing happens and that's not helpful not
only is it not helpful because you can't
solve problems and you're in that state
it's not helpful because you start to
panic and that is super scary and it's
also not helpful because it suppresses
your immune system so I get home there's
nobody here and in a time of crisis
where do you want to be with your family
you want to be somewhere safe and so my
borrowing this term span of control what
is it well
it's a term carry Lorenz happen to be
the first f-14 Tomcat pilot in the
history of the United States and she's
one of my dear friends and the military
turns span of control is this idea that
when you're a crisis which you're in
right now because there's so much
uncertainty you're okay right now but
there's so much uncertainty out there in
order to calm your anxiety and focus
your mind you've got a narrow your span
of control and the way that I did that
for myself is very simple I want you to
pick three things today that you need to
do that will make you feel safe and that
will make you feel safe regarding your
family or safer and that will make you
feel a little bit more prepared for
being still or being isolated for the
next three weeks let's just start there
okay and I want you to write those in
the comments what do you need to do
three things
in order for you to feel safe in order
for your family to feel a little bit
safer and in order for you to feel like
you could be where you are or get to the
place you need to get to so that if you
were just sitting there for three weeks
you were gonna be good okay just
focusing on those three things was super
helpful for me because it meant I don't
need to worry about whether or not
they're grounding domestic air travel
right now I don't need to worry about
whether or not Walt Disney is closed I
don't need to worry about what's gonna
happen in May or June we all know
there's been there is a global pandemic
and we know
that there's been a stock market
collapse and we if you've been paying
attention to the news you know that the
world is in a messy place the first
thing I would offer to you with great
humility is I would remind you to stay
centered and to avoid dropping into the
mass hysteria that we're seeing people
fall into I'm not saying don't watch the
news I'm saying watch the news
selectively I'm saying don't be
concerned I think we should all be
concerned and I think we should all be
prepared but I think there's a
difference between you know allowing
fear to take you over and being prepared
but also being positive realizing this
eventually will pass and messy times
make Greater leaders and everyday heroes
so one thing I would say is you know
remember to bring on your kindness I was
reading about a couple who stocked up on
Lysol wipes and then we're selling them
to make this huge profit and I'm not
judging I'm just saying you know we are
brothers and sisters on a small planet
right now and I think we all need to
roll up our sleeves and of course
protect your family but also bring your
humanity to your community and do
whatever you can help other people the
second thing I would say is a lot of
people have followed me our business
people a lot of leaders a lot of
entrepreneurs keep on asking yourself
this fundamentally important question
which is how can I deliver even more
value to my marketplace how can I
deliver even more value to the
marketplace how can I help even more
people how can I be even more of use to
my customers and the people who I do
business with because the marketplace
will always reward your mastery
especially in difficult times personally
I would say over communicate with your
family show them even more love show
them that they are
safe I would also say this is an amazing
time to look at your insecurities in
times of sunshine and times of ease we
don't really we often don't look at
ourselves I think this is a great time
to develop your mindset to strengthen
your heart set to optimize your health
set to escalate your soul set the for
interior empires that I teach and if
you're scared right now if you're
insecure right now if you're losing your
energy right now if you're unfocused
right now if you're worried right now if
you're sticking your head in to the sand
like an ostrich right now if you're
suffering from normalcy bias I've been
talking to some people they think
everything's okay I don't think
everything is okay and so normally
normalcy bias is a human tendency born a
fear to say everything is okay and that
could get you in a lot of trouble right
now I'm saying stay positive
stay centered stay focused
be prepared if you were in Italy right
now what would you do what steps would
you take as a businessman as a
businessman I think I think what I've
heard humming on that too because Italy
did just shut down all them its business
all pharmacies are open right now yeah
so it's commercially closed there's not
a lot you can do right now however they
don't shut down the internet correct so
if you're selling products online then
you are okay if you're selling products
that are subscription-based models
learning from home things drop shipping
miles they're out so I don't need to
start considering let's say yourself
things that um but you're not using drop
shipping now then you would transition
to drop shipping you could try to do
things where you're actually man you
forget if the manufacturing is occurring
outside of Italy if distribution occurs
outside Italy then yeah your customers
are outside of Italy guess what you can
keep going here but you know this
remember um this phase will pass where a
country is on lock then what they try to
do right now is stop the speed of
transmission not so that people won't
get it
people everyone's gonna get it all right
from what I've heard from very very well
informed sources doctors experts in
epidemiology all right they expect
anywhere from 40 to 70% of the human
population to eventually get coronavirus
not in this novel version number 19
right why because nobody has natural
community in it's highly contagious what
they're trying to do that was slow the
spread of the virus so it's not to
overwhelm the healthcare systems because
here's the deal most people that get
this are gonna be just fine it's for
people that are young it barely affects
the rental all people in their 20s 30s
no big problem there are some
complications especially if you have
some health complications before ever
for the most part generally speaking
it's not a death sentence for people
that get into 2013 40s or 50s even right
we get your sixties and seventies
especially a compromising subway you got
a serious chance of it becoming either
fatal or Cup requiring serious
hospitalization intervention and being
intubated
perhaps there's you know support needed
for your kidneys and your heart whatever
that might be what they can't afford
right now is for all the cases that come
in at once so what they trying to do
your slow down the transmission not stop
it slow down the transmission so the
healthcare system can deal with it over
time versus all at once and will
collapse the system and the people that
really need care most older people
immunocompetent pregnant women
I think of personal - right but they all
everyone's rushing in at once there's
not enough to just to go around to
intubate people first off a couple
things about the coronavirus obviously
it's the only news that anyone is
looking at today and you know all these
travel bans been put in place all these
events are canceled and it's said all
these jobs are being lost where people
are scared about their own jobs and
their own careers so just a couple of
thoughts about the corona virus I think
we don't actually know for instance many
numbers we don't know how many people
have already been infected but don't
have symptoms we also don't know what
the fatality rate is because if the bulk
of the people have been infected with no
symptoms then we don't have a true
picture of the fatality rate so for
instance with stars or or h1n1 in 2009
we originally thought that fatality rate
was like three or four percent it turned
out to be 0.01% when we found out that
millions of people were already infected
but they recovered without having any
symptoms the other thing to look for in
the data with corona virus is how
quickly do countries like South Korea
and now we'll see Italy how quickly you
know the at first we see in fact the
cases go up like this they double every
day but then we started to see it level
off we saw that in China we've seen it
in South Korea hopefully we'll see it in
Italy that's the next country that was
out of our
amount of infections the reason China
and South Korea went like this to this
is two reasons one is social distancing
and quarantine and the other is as more
and more people get it more more people
get immune there's a herd immunity and
that might happen here in the US so
we're still in this period in the US but
eventually we'll be in this period so
the worst case that's gonna happen the
worst case scenario is that this goes a
little too far and our healthcare system
is like this but my guess is because of
all the social distancing that's
happening now meaning people aren't
going to events as much and we're seeing
this in all the data people aren't
traveling flights are empty the NBA is
canceled meetings are getting canceled
we'll start to see the number of
infected cases start to flatten so look
for that in the data look for that in
the next 30 days or less the other thing
we're seeing with the kind of the other
thing we're seeing with the current is
that massive stimulus is being put into
the economy that doesn't matter so much
as people are getting sick and dying but
it'll matter in the long run in terms of
people's jobs careers money situation
and so on we are seeing social
distancing happening we're seeing these
travel ban so it does suggest to me that
eventually will stop spiking and we'll
see the number of new cases starting to
flatten we're also there's also work on
a cure so so keep track of that there is
a lot of fake news about cures but I
would look into you know if you google
this yourself I'm not gonna recommend
anything but if you see things that were
sort of herbal remedies for things like
malaria or things that affected the
immune system consider getting those but
what I want to talk about really is not
the corona virus but everybody is waking
up anxious oh so someone has how much is
media driven a lot is media driven and a
lot now is political but people this is
an exponentially growing disease that is
causing some fatalities my guess is the
final fatality rate won't be anywhere
near 2% it'll be somewhere between 0.1
and 0.5% and I'm I'm basing this not on
my own research but on what other expert
immunologists have told me on my podcast
again um let's let's look at the anxiety
I wake up anxious not only for myself
but I know a lot of people who are
losing jobs they're losing income
opportunities and it scares me not just
for them but for society says if society
as a whole is anxious then decisions
decisions will be made that are
irrational people when people are
panicking they don't make rational
decisions
so the key now is to focus on yourself
being as rational as possible so you
could avoid making decisions that might
harm yourself might harm your family
might harm your job don't make
irrational decisions now while data is
still kind of being gathered and again
what we're seeing is a massive stimulus
I mean the New York Federal Reserve just
announced they're putting a trillion and
a half dollars into the economy that's
gonna drive up a lot of different
markets regardless of what happens with
the virus that's what they did in 2009
which effectively saved the economy
there's also going to be kind of a it
seems like there'll be some income tax
relief at some point and there's various
other measures in terms of money that
are going to help people
what is that party people this is my
daily quarantine coronavirus check-in I
just did a an interview with dr. Judd
Brewer and we were talking about anxiety
through these times how to mitigate that
how to cope with being out and about are
sorry not being able to go out and about
and the interview is live now by the way
so go check it out I think it's really
good he has some amazing advice his
specialty is anxiety addiction recovery
breaking habit loops he talks pretty
powerfully about how anxiety and worry
are more habits than they are anything
else and and how to break out of that
but anyway the punchline of his episode
is you guys know the last question that
I ask is around well in this case what's
the thing that people could do that
would have the biggest impact on their
anxiety and ability to get through the
very bizarre very uncertain times and he
said connection and I was very surprised
by that he recommends a cuddling a pet
if you have it certainly cuddling a
loved one we talked about reading books
being a possible way for people that are
completely isolated if you didn't have
access to the Internet
stay positive you know the money doesn't
disappear things just move make room for
what you want I will tell you that I've
lived through 97 2001 2008 and now this
time every single one of those periods
of my life and there'd be the best time
and you know had a great analogy there's
young mentee of mine Jeff Fenster owns a
ton of ever bull franchises and
multi-millionaire just a great kid but
he used the analogy one in which he
gives me credit for but I don't remember
but he said remember in Forrest Gump
when him with Lieutenant Dan and he went
out on the water in the big storm and
you know they couldn't find any shrimp
until they would because everybody was
shrimping but they'd go out there in the
storm and they'd get all the shrimp
because they stayed out there right it's
time to stay out there it's time to know
and utilize the skills knowledge and
desire that you have if you want more
advice wisdom guidance from other
successful entrepreneurs on how you can
navigate the coronavirus situation check
out the video right there next to me I
hope you find it valuable and continue
to believe and I'll see you there